money everyone yeah thank you
I gotta say it has been amazing to see
the runaway success of your game what's
it been like for you oh it's been
immense I mean really the reaction we've
got from players and content creators
has been tremendous and I want to say
thank you to everyone for that it's been
great and thank you for the experiences
both of the joy of winning and be well I
guess the joy of a bullet flying through
my head out of nowhere and I'll never
know why you gotta learn to love the
salt love us well I understand that even
though a lot of people treat the game
almost as a full release right now yeah
it's still technically not released yet
and there's a whole lot more to come
talk to us a little bit about what's in
store so we have our folks at the moment
is to sort of stabilize the game that
the server's up to spec but also we have
you know 2d 3d replays planned for
in-game replays we've new weapons coming
every month so yeah no way but our
current focus is ready to just get the
game competitive and stable so suddenly
fences are no longer the most impossible
object in the game right I'm over the
yeah yeah so our content program
programmer mark he's done a really great
job getting this system to be dynamic so
doesn't matter what object you're in
front of you'll jump right over it yeah
so in terms of jumping and vaulting is
it yeah ball tank is it is it sort of
when you say that it's dynamic does this
mean that the taller the obstacle the
more difficult it is to climb over yeah
exactly it has different animations for
each different things so vaulting
climbing now we also have weather so one
of my favorite aspects of course is the
rain map in the game walk me through it
we're seeing here so this is our new
weather settings this is fog you just
saw a clear day our rain is being
tweaked a little bit as well and we also
have our sunset coming in so this really
I'm really happy with how this turned
out it's that's your cue oh yeah and
what is the impact on gameplay of these
types of things with life just changed
dynamic oh so this is Oh new gun yes
this is the OTS Groza it's a 7.62
bullpup super-powerful crate only yeah
it's going to be a beast is it it's a
short-range long-range we're medium to
medium short to medium is going to be a
beast it's going to be super powerful
that long range it'll work as well and I
remember before you came on the show I
asked why did you put that gun in it I
think your answer was she looks cool it
looks cool yeah it's it's like we wanted
to add a bullpup when we wanted to add
something else to 7.62 class and this is
a Spetsnaz weapon it's yeah it just
looks great it looks cool a good as
reason as any honestly I want to come
back to the weather effects obviously
they look beautiful what are some of the
impacts that you've seen on the gameplay
with the new weather effects well it's
just going to change the way you play so
it's not necessarily gonna be you're
gonna be sniping all the time you know
with the foggy weather you're gonna have
to choose a more kind of cbq type play
style but it's just again to give you a
bit of variety and make every game kind
of different you've talked a little bit
about what we've seen in the video but
talk to me about long-term what's far
down the line for player unknowns
battlegrounds so again we want to finish
up the platform and make it a good
platform for all kind of game modes you
know we will have modding down the line
as well yeah and it's again it's just
creating a stable platform that's a game
here I understand they're also working
on new maps yeah so we have two new maps
coming one based in Peru a desert map
with sort of rune cities with sandstorms
and stuff that's awesome yeah and then
this other one in the Adriatic so it has
even a ruined cosmodrome in the center
of the map with like snowfall and it's
yes I'm exact also and I know that
you've been super involved with the
community of regular players what's in
store for those people playing the game
right now so I said we have our custom
games we have the 3d replays which I'm
really excited about because it allows
you to watch your match back in the
engine with a free cam and slow-motion
some bracelets aren't great exactly
right so you can just create it yeah
yeah and it yeah it'll just give you a
new way to create like machinima so
Savoie that within the game yeah and the
last thing I want to bring up because
you were mentioning this a lot before
you came on you have all sorts of
stability and performance fixes incoming
yeah so like our focus this month is
honour save server performance and
really getting that stable because at
the moment the server's aren't
performing the best they could but you
know so last month our team's focus was
on client performance and we approved
that broadly for a lot of people and
this month it's on server so they've
already found a lot of things to fix
I'm excited that's great I'm sure
players will comply
really stop blaming anything on the game
of that place they will accept
responsibility for those losses then
well two player unknown himself Brendan
thank you so much for coming out you so
much pleasure thank you everyone
[Applause]